what will it be like for you
given that this show is a show that gets
emotional yep gets it's a toll and you
even have those episodes where you look
back you know at this whole journey what
will it be like for you to relive some
of the things you've been through oh
you're right it's gonna be hard i know
it'll be emotional but um i honestly i'm
in a it's gonna sound weird to say i'm
looking forward to it but i do think
that there will be some very you know
therapeutic cathartic moments on this
show
i you know i want to dance to nick's
song
[Music]
i want that moment i know he'll be with
me on the dance floor every single time
i mean he's a performer we met in a
broadway show um so i
i know it'll be tough but in a weird way
i kind of really look forward to that
that moment where i get to dance to his
music what would he think of you doing
this whole thing oh he'd be like yeah
baby
he'd be so happy
i mean he knows how much i loved this
show i've watched this show since season
one really okay yes stacy keebler still
goes down in my hands like one of my
favorites but yeah i i know he would be
so excited for me i noticed you wearing
the elvis necklace that's so cute yeah
always i don't take that off does he
know does he get that mom's doing a
dancing competition and mom's dancing
again i mean i don't think so he's two
so i'm not too sure what he fully
understands but he does say whenever i
leave the house he goes mama goes to
work and i go mama goes to work so
that's so cute i love that it's really
cool i know and the best part is when i
walk in the door at the end of the day
and he runs up to me and gives me the
biggest hug and kiss and i'm just like
oh my god it's the best who's gonna
watch the little guy is he in the bubble
with you and we'll see him in the
audience
i hope so um he's definitely in my
bubble all the time my mom and dad are
coming here for the next couple months
hopefully till the end and um they're
going to help me with elvis what made
you want to do dancing with the stars
you know i used to dance i used to
perform and
so much of my life has changed since
that time so when i got this phone call
it was like i have to do this because
that that used to be my life
and i can't i can't wait to get it back
what is it going to feel like to go to
your past and you noted how much has
changed since then well i will tell you
ballroom dancing is nothing like
broadway or the rockettes i swear these
rehearsals are so hard i have to throw
everything i know out the window and
literally learn
a whole new style styles of dance it's
completely different um it's gonna be
amazing though i love learning i love
rehearsing i'm having so much fun
already you watch the show so you know
people are gonna say she has an
advantage she's a dancer yes oh my gosh
i'm telling you what you guys if you
could see these rehearsals you would
know that i have no advantage right now
i'm telling you it is a whole it's like
a new language it's like you know
english but now you're learning french
and it's starting from scratch seriously
i mean when you know my dancing partner
you can ask him it's it's starting from
scratch and what a rehearsal has been
like so far for you physically oh my
gosh so hard i have
horrible blister on my toe
my shoulder and arm is there in pain i
mean i'm telling you
ballroom dancing is unlike any other
dancing and my partner is amazing and as
he's moving around the floor i literally
just stare at him and i'm just smiling
because i'm like wow like you're amazing
like they're just so good so did you get
the partner you thought you were gonna
get i got the best partner oh just wait
and see okay who do you think your
biggest competition is oh gosh you know
i feel like dark horses i might i might
go with like cody rixby oh he's he's fit
he's very fit yeah and you know he's i
feel like he's gonna be sassy out there
now you do know a certain someone carry
anaba yes i do you're a little familiar
so what has carrie ann told you she gave
me any advice oh my gosh i love her so
much and i told her i said you better be
hard on me and she was like oh don't you
know i will and then she said she was
good and she's so right she was like
find your primal energy and i love that
so that's going to be my my theme find
my primal energy because she that's
interesting because she has she knows
you she does know me and i think that
she knows what this means for me to be
dancing again i think you know she's a
dancer she gets it she understands what
it's like to leave it and then try to
find it again well what does it mean for
you
i mean just to find that part of myself
again to do something for me you know
you you go through what i went through
you become a mom you lose yourself you
know you gain a lot of things in life
but you also lose that part of yourself
so this
means a lot to me to like kind of find
that part of myself again
what did carrie anne tell you might be
your struggles or things you you're
gonna have to overcome oh and she's
absolutely right she didn't hold back no
dancing with a partner i've never danced
i've never partnered because i'm so tall
on broadway i'm just never partnered
with a guy so
to allow somebody else to lead to follow
and and to hold you know my ground still
it's that's going to be a challenge for
me it already has been but she's right
she knows by the way it's nice for you
guys to see each other again because i'm
sure you'll miss her on the top yes oh
my gosh i told her i was like i get to
see you again
i love her so much so i i know it'll be
from afar and a judge's table but i
still can't wait to like see her from
apart was that surprising when she gave
you guys that news
carrie anne has just you know had such a
you know hard year with her health i
support her in every decision she makes
she knows what's best for her and i
think that she knew that this was the
best decision for her and her well-being
and last question new host coming to the
talk
what can you tell us about what to
expect and what do you think of this new
makeup oh my gosh first of all i love
akbar from the first time he co-hosted
with us i ran over to him and i was like
you're amazing oh my gosh
his energy his stature he's just class
act i love the guy
um he's a father i think he's you know i
think he's a great addition i think it's
going to be a really cool season 12.